katarina you were pushed to the brink it
seemed in this game but you managed to
hold the draw tell us how it happened
i think i got a very nice opening
i thought maybe i have some advantage
and then i totally gave it away and then
i was just like super suffering
and what what made it made you come back
in the game
well i don't think it was that easy for
tata to figure out how to how to
actually push more because the pawn is
stopped but it's unclear i think how to
continue so i was just trying not to
like not to do anything too serious not
to get too low on time and just make
some moves and and hope for the best
it ended up really good for you at some
point uh in fact in the end game maybe
was the rook g2 move that was a slip
that prevents your king from coming out
uh i think we can get to this position
in the game itself
we're coming up on it right here were
you starting to get optimistic in this
position or still thinking it was close
to a draw no this i was very happy
because now i'm pawn up i'm holding on
to the d4 pawn the bishop on h8 it's
like very passive but doing an amazing
job covering the pawn on d4 and stopping
the knight from you know checkmate
checking me or i was worried about
knight f6 so much i was like it doesn't
work there is the bishop
it's defending it uh and the pawn on h4
is you know it's a huge weakness so
rookie four is the only move
and i just missed that she has perpetual
but i'm not sure if there is anything
else i can do
we were thinking with g1 katja so after
rook g1
uh
least with the idea of king g6 yeah but
then uh let's see she gives check and
then transfers the knight to the center
yep 95
or even 92 looks a little dangerous to
rihanna because no okay b6 is hanging
the bishop you know rook h7 is threat at
any moment
so back king e2 king d2 sorry
okay how did uh i love your active king
i love your active rook but now the
bishop is a problem well i think if i
get you know i've got ideas you know
what i mean i think that this is the way
you could have prolonged the game or
continue to get the problem rook g2
was an immediate draw immediate
perpetual but yes sir if she takes on b6
and puts the knight on c4 that's
something like how do you think bishop
f4
sure uh
keep going bishop e5 bishop e5 knight b6
check on f4
d3
and
it it's in your favor i don't know if
you can win it i'm not saying it i'm
saying if you wanted to plural along the
game you said you're upon up you're
beginning to feel a little optimistic
let's go go then rook g1 was the way you
could go go go yeah i missed the i
missed the perpetual yeah it's a nice
resource for her it still looks good it
still looks like it's not a win but it
definitely kept the game going you are
leading from round one tie for first
it's the first time now where you're
actually trailing by half a point with
four rounds to go your thoughts on that
it's okay
i think i'm still kind of uh doing well
i mean this was a very tough game i
think tatev was pushing so i'm happy i
survived i had black i was worse at some
moment so i think it's all good let's
move on tomorrow with white
who do you play tomorrow
with wife
i know i invited megan lee who won today
and you have white okay okay thank you
[Laughter]
all right we'll let you go rest perfect
eat prepare awesome thank you so much or
eat rest prepared
repeat
okay back to the game of